tu serais pas mandat lire par hasard oui
et c'est pas par hasard ça fait court
est rencontré ton double ça m'est déjà
arrivé je au cours de certains de mes
concerts les deux premiers rangs sont
plaints de solides amanda lear mais
genre dans un miroir déformant
traficoter un petit peu la charge et
c'était que ça fait un peu peur je je je
trouves tu ne trouves comment mieux qu'à
la télé oui puis à l'odeur il ya ce
parfum en deux temps c'est mieux je
trouve en vrai donc étoiles matin quand
il te regarde dans la glace a tu trouves
comment tu fais avec difficulté non
parce que le matin si j'ai les yeux qui
sont pas tout à fait ouverts et quand
finalement je me trouve c'est un petit
peu un choc et puis après on salut fis
temps quand était toute petite durée
mais ressent bien qu i am et l'ouest
j'adorerais mais ouest cette auto ironie
ce sens à dire ision sens de l'humour
dédramatiser aussi le sexe ça me
plaisait beaucoup et puis après je les
rencontre et ça continue est mon idole
mais vous coûtera moins
non non pas vraiment c'était pas mon nom
c'était pas du tout le genre de personne
qui me plaisait qui m'attire et qu'ils
fassent ils citent ya vu une baguette
magique tu changerais quoi en toi rien
rien n'a changé en rien acheter tout
bien maintenant et content d'elle et
qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy mon cul
de l'avis général le même clou se
feraient l'amour avec moi a fait
beaucoup de contraintes
il faudrait vraiment m'y obligeait et
peut-être me donner des sous en plus et
c'était bien payé tu t'y prendre et
comment au jeu fermeraient les yeux
je penserai à quelqu'un d'autre je pense
que c'est ce que je ferai xo fort à très
bien c'est bon à savoir tu m'aimes un
peu quand même
il ya il ya beaucoup d'amour il ya
beaucoup de ncc conflictuelle c'est
difficile de lire les quelqu'un comme
toi et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
winne a l'habitude
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus